In League of Legends, when your back's up against the wall,
when your HP bar is down to a sliver of imperceptively small health, amazing things can happen.
Whether it’s an outplay that turns into a near death experience, a last ditch Hail Mary effort
at defending a burning Nexus,
or an escape that defies the odds,
these next plays have gone down in League of Legends history as iconic low health moments.
(casting)
I’m Colin for theScore esports, and today we’re talking about the best in
heart stoppingly low health plays of League of Legends.
After all, health is a resource,
and usually when that resource gets dangerously low,
it's time to go back to base, get a couple items,  take a breather.
Sometimes though, you don't have the chance.
The TPs are coming in, the gank is on, and all there is left to do is fight.
you have to be prefect or you die.
(casting)
While going for glory with an invisible health bar may seem tempting,
sometimes discretion is the better part of valor.
Just take these next death-defyingly low HP escapes, for instance.
(casting)
Okay, guys, when it comes to low HP plays, you know it's not just about champions, right?
The Nexus, after all, has its own health bar.
And when that health bar gets low, things can get nuts.
(casting)
Surviving with just a sliver of health is probably the most nerve-wracking thing that can happen
in a game of League of Legends.
I don't know about you guys, but I was sweating bullets just watching those clips.
And I can't take anymore.
If you’ve got an idea for a  topic, player or team you want us to cover in our next video,
let me know it comments below, and I'll see you next week.